American consumers are bombarded with
nutritional advice to our detriment
argues marion Nestle in her new book
food politics it details how the food
industry through lobbying advertising
and the co-opting of experts influences
our dietary choices resulting in
epidemic obesity increased vulnerability
to heart and lung disease cancer and
Stroke this talk from the Harvard coupe
in Cambridge Massachusetts is 45 minutes
we're very excited to be hosting marion
Nestle who'll be speaking about her new
book food politics how they food
industry influences nutrition and health
food is on our minds and not just what
we're having for dinner more and more we
are paying increased intention to what
exactly it is that we are eating and why
two weeks ago Michael Pollan published
an expose on the beef industry in the
New York Times many of you may have read
it Eric Schlosser's Fast Food Nation is
the bestseller here and in other
bookstores around the nation we've
instituted a new food section in our
store to house all the books being
written about food and its political and
cultural manifestations at the same time
as we were paying all this attention to
food we were flooded with examples of
big businesses working hand-in-hand with
the government and not necessarily in
the interests of regular consumers the
importance of food politics is that it
addresses both of these topics marion
Nestle pursues the question of what the
what role the food industry plays in
creating an environment so conducive to
overeating and poor nutritional
practices and so confusing about basic
process basic principles of diet and
health she exposes a ways in which the
food companies use political processes
to obtain government and professional
support for the sale of their products
reading food politics can be
overwhelming but reading it is necessary
if you want to know the truth about what
and why you were eating marion Nestle
has devoted her career to issues a food
health and nutrition she is professor
and chair of the department of nutrition
in food studies at New York University
author of nutrition and clinical
practice she has served as a nutrition
policy advisor to the Department of
Health and Human Services and as a
member of nutrition and
advisory communities to the Department
of Agriculture and the FDA she
frequently writes in lecturers about a
broad range of topics related to food
and nutritional policy and I'm very
excited that she's here to speak with us
today the format for this afternoon is
follows Professor mon-sol will speak for
about roughly a half an hour about her
book that will be followed by roughly 20
minutes of question-and-answer
discussion time and then we'll have a
brief book signing copies of the book
are available at the front of the store
near the registers on the front table
and next to the food and sustainability
display that we have in the next room so
with that thank you Amanda I'm very
pleased to be here my first academic job
was at Brandeis University I hate to say
how long ago it was and I'm particularly
excited to see colleagues from their
neighbors and my freshman college
roommates and other people who are here
thank you so much for coming and I wish
I could make it more comfortable for you
it's really okay if you kind of hang out
and climb the walls I wrote this book
not as an expose of the food industry
but really because I wanted to point out
to people how what the food industry
does influences what we eat and I pick
the word influence very carefully I
don't use a tack I don't use fault and I
don't use blame and so the book came out
about a month ago and I've the question
that I get asked most frequently is
what's been the reaction to your book
and so I thought I would talk about what
the reaction to the book has been and
then read you a few sections of what I
actually say about the things that
people are reacting to because the
reactions to it fall into two categories
the very small number of people who've
actually read the book man thinks it's
only been out for a little while and the
very large number of people who think
that they know what it says without
reading it so the the attack on it began
on February 22nd when a website called
junk science dot-com
displayed an article by somebody named
Steven Malloy who is identified as the
scholar at the Cato Institute who says
the food industry
so all the way to the bank as it
manipulates the system to make us fat
and unhealthy
that's Marian Nestle's junk science
field message in her new book Nestle who
portrays herself as an above the fray
professor of nutrition at New York
University spends more than 400 pages
accusing the food industry of
influencing the government co-opting
nutritional nutrition professionals
exploiting children and corrupting
schools all in the name of profit the
book won't be in stores until March but
the marketing campaign was already have
started with predictably superficial and
uncritical reviews in the New York Times
and USA Today despite its length the
book was a quick read and disintegrated
from a scientific perspective on pages 7
& 8 those two pages are where Nestle
tries to establish the American diet as
a health problem the necessary
foundation for the rest of the book the
combination of poor diet sedentary
lifestyle and excessive alcohol
consumption contributes to about four
hundred thousand to two million or so
annual deaths in the u.s. about the same
number and proportion affected by
cigarette smoking rights Nestle I did
indeed write that this assertion extends
the discredited claim that obesity kills
300,000 people annually the writer then
goes on to explain how I have my SIA
science wrong how I parrot government
claims that rates of overweight and
obese children and adults are
skyrocketing when we know that's not
true
he refers to that as folklore and then
he talked he makes a lot of then he
makes a lot of personal comments which I
won't bother to read and says that food
politics deftly glosses over in
misrepresents the science on diet and
health and Nestle's personal bias pardon
me if I'm a little skeptical of the rest
of her hatchet job on the food industry
okay keep that in mind we'll come back
to that then the email started lots of
people read junk science dot-com on the
Internet
here's one that came soon after Marian
have you ever accidentally even eaten a
cheeseburger I know I have not when are
you going to hold people responsible for
their own decisions and choices do
people not have any
willpower or self-control this is
ridiculous obese people should blame
themselves
people who smoke they make the choice to
smoke are you going to rob some little
kid of a great experience who at age
four wants to go to McDonald's with his
mom and dad well that is where you were
going great companies will be afraid to
market their products here's another
email I would like to know where in the
Constitution is the government given the
power to regulate what we eat when we
are told that our taxes will pay for
abortions regardless of our religious
belief we are told that the woman has a
right to choose what she does with her
own body doesn't that same right apply
to those who want to put junk food in
their bodies I would love to see you try
explaining that using the same arguments
as for health risks reading your book
might raise my blood pressure so in the
interest of health I think I'll avoid
reading it and go have a cinnamon bun
and a cup of tea Dennis Avery who is a
senior fellow for the Hudson Institute
and director of the Center for global
food issues a very conservative person
who weighs in often on these things says
I am so relieved I thought I was 15
pounds overweight because I indulge in
too much good food and too little
exercise but marion Nestle tells me it's
not my fault at all she says I'm fat
because of food ads run by big
corporations and he goes on to talk
about how ridiculous that is
he says dr. Nestle would like us to eat
plant-based diets but most of our fats
and sugars come from plants and meats
give us important macronutrients Marion
says the restaurants make the portions
too big if they made my sausage
McMuffins smaller I'm rich enough to buy
- she hates sugared soft drinks but coke
offers diet coke with no calories and
apple juice has lots of sugar will
guards be stationed in grocery aisles
besides lawsuits she is pushing for a
multi-billion dollar tax on bad foods
with the revenue used for government
nutrition campaigns sorry Marion but our
love for food and relaxation probably
can't be tempered by suing big food or
banning snack food from our stores
governmental edicts that take away our
personal choices have never won much
success in America we'll have to saw
this the hard way now I am NOT without
defenders who have also not read the
book and this is from Sheldon Rampton
who I don't know personally but who's
written a very amusing book called toxic
sludge is good for you which is a book
about the public relations industry and
he writes on amazon.com the Public
Relation campaign against this book has
already begun for what it's worth
potential readers of Nestle's book
should note that the first reader
reviews of this book are pretty
obviously cranked out by some food
industry public relations campaign to
begin with they were all submitted on
the same date February 22nd reader
reviews of a book that isn't even
scheduled to go on sale until March 4th
for another they hit on the same message
points that critics are nagging nannies
whipping up hysteria on the behalf of
greedy trial lawyers etc February 22nd
is also the date that noted industry
flack Stephen Malloy of the junk science
homepage wrote a review trashing
Nestle's book Malloy is a former tobacco
lobbyist and frontman for group created
by Philip Morris which has been
diversifying its tobacco holdings I
didn't know that in recent years by
buying up companies that make many of
the fatty sugar legen Laden foods that
Nestle is warning about I haven't had a
chance to read Nestle's book myself but
it irritates me to see the food
industry's PR machine spew out the usual
every time somebody writes something
they don't like if they hate her this
much it's probably a pretty good book
the last comment that i will read is are
excerpts from a letter from Venable
bethe Howard and civiletti
Attorneys at Law via facsimile and
certified mail dated March 27th Rea
inaccurate sugar statements we represent
the sugar Association incorporated an
organization that is committed to
integrity and sound scientific
principles in educating consumers and
professionals about the benefits of pure
natural sugar we understand that you
were a professor at New York
University's School of Education and
chair of its Department of nutrition and
food studies and that you have recently
published a book entitled food politics
which you are currently promoting it has
come to our attention that during the
course of this
promotion you have made numerous false
misleading disparaging and defamatory
statements about sugar I'm being mean to
sugar while we are perplexed as to why
or how a professional educator of your
stature would disseminate such distorted
and damaging statements we must demand
that you stop making such statements
about sugar there are numerous examples
of some statements some of which we will
provide below first you continually
repeat the false and inaccurate
statement that soft drinks contain sugar
for example in any court they quote a
radio interview you said soft drinks are
really an easy target because their
sugar and water and nothing else
guilty as commonly known by experts in
the fields of nutrition soft drinks have
contained virtually no sugar in
parentheses sucrose in more than twenty
years the misuse of the word sugar to
indicate other caloric sweeteners is not
only inaccurate but is a grave
disservice to the thousands of family
farmers who grow sugar cane and sugar
beets now I'll just have a little
scientific thing here sucrose is a
double molecule of glucose and fructose
soft drinks are done with corn
sweeteners which have glucose and
fructose but they're already separated I
leave it to you to decide whether
they're different or the same then it
goes on with a lot of other things that
I won't bother to deal with but they end
with we also ask that you be more
precise and accurate in your definitions
and cease making misleading or false
statements regarding sugar or the sugar
industry if not the only recourse
available to us will be to legally
defend our industry and its members
against any and all fallacious and
harmful allegations now I've posted all
this on my website food politics.com
should anybody want to read what them in
their entirety let me read you what the
book says about sugar this book is about
the politics of food and this is about
the politics of sugar and I begin by
discussing sugar in the context of
Dietary Guidelines for Americans which
are the government's statements about
what you're supposed to eat to obtain a
healthful diet
and the guide the current guideline
prepared by a committee in 2000 was
choose beverages and foods to moderate
your intake of sugars okay sugar was one
of the more contentious guidelines in
the 2000 edition largely because of
industry arguments that research on
sugar and disease did not support a
recommendation to eat less one of the
theses of the book is that the food
industry has to sell food that's what
their job is and that's a need more
message the progression of this
guideline is especially revealing the
committee report in September 1999 said
go easy on beverages and foods high in
added sugars go easy and added or the
operative words in February 2000 the
guideline was changed to choose
beverages and foods that limit your
intake of sugars limit in May 2000 the
Department of Agriculture overrode the
committee report and changed the
guideline to choose beverages and foods
to moderate your intake of sugars so
limit was changed to moderate and that
word added sugars was dropped ok how did
that happen go easy means eat less and
added distinguishes processed foods from
fruits and vegetables that naturally
contain sugar the committee report
explains that the added sugars displace
nutrient containing foods in the diet
and that a focus on total sugars is not
supported by the literature and causes
confusion among consumers although the
text of the final version states that
soft drinks candy cake cookies fruit
drinks and dairy desserts are the major
sources of added sugars the guideline
itself obscures that point it does as
does the positive word choose as opposed
to the restrictive go easy the report
offers no explanation for the softening
of this recommendation leaving readers
to surmise that the committee must have
agreed with the grocery manufacturers of
America that the minimum burden of
scientific proof has not been met for
more restrictive advice investigative
reports revealed fierce in industry
lobbying to retain the wording choose a
diet moderate in sugars that had been
put out in 1995 sugar trade association
viewed limit as the
disaster for their 26 billion dollar
industry and their lobbyists induced 30
senators half from sugar growing states
to question whether the USDA had the
right to change the sugar guidelines
based on existing science the trade
associations also objected to singling
out individual foods and beverages as
major food sources of sugars instead
according to another account the grocery
manufacturers wanted recommendations
related to meals and snacks would avoid
creation which would avoid creation of a
good versus bad food scenario and would
be more in line with the practical
advice of health professionals who urged
consumers to look at their food in takes
over time instead of on a single food or
beverage basis let's go on to another
section about sugar which is about
buying access and influence in which I
deal with the question do campaign
contributions trips and presents by
corporate influence over government
decisions much evidence suggests that
they do and in proportion to the amounts
spent and in this and I have a section
here called getting sweet attention this
example concerns sugar a top of the
pyramid food that provides calories but
no other nutrients government dietary
guidelines suggest moderation and we
know where that came from in sugar
consumption nevertheless for more than
200 years the United States has
controlled the price of sugar first to
raise revenue but later to protect the
economic interests of domestic producers
for this commodity the relationship
between agriculture policy and health is
unusually complex as a result of an
elaborate system of price support
programs and import tariffs and quotas
codified during the Depression in early
years of World War two Americans pay
artificially high prices for sugar a
practice that cost consumers 1.9 billion
dollars in 1998 from a nutritional
standpoint higher sugar prices might be
a useful disincentive to consuming soft
drinks desserts and candy but from a
financial standpoint the policy is
highly undesirable
besides the harm it causes consumers the
windfall benefits a surprisingly small
number of sugar producers in 1991 for
example 15
and farms raves raised sugarcane and
sugar beets in the United States but 42%
of the sugar subsidies went to went just
1% of these growers those must be the
poor family sugar raisers that the sugar
Association is concerned about the
owners of these few farms give
generously to both political parties the
fun Ewell family for example controls
about one-third of Florida's sugar cane
production and collects at least sixty
million dollars annually in subsidies
the finals contributed more than 350,000
to the two political parties more two
Democrats and Republicans this was
during the Clinton administration
through their flow son companies in 1997
to 1998 in 2000 Alfonso Fanueil hosted a
dinner attended by President Clinton
that raised more than a million dollars
for the Florida Democratic Party sugar
cane production is concentrated in two
southern states Florida and Louisiana
where working conditions of migrant cane
field workers from Caribbean countries
have raised human rights concerns
environmentalists view the Florida cane
fields is blocking the free flow of
water from the Everglades sugarcane
companies in particular those owned by
the fine Ewell family have successfully
resisted attempts to mandate
improvements in working conditions or
the return of cane fields to marshland
in order to protect the Everglades
investigative reporters for Time
magazine described how the funnels use
their political connections to avoid
having to pay for cleaning up the
Everglades even if their account
misrepresented the family's actions as
one critical response has claimed the
finals indisputably have unusual access
to the highest levels of government the
most stunning example of such access is
documented in of all unexpected places
the Starr report the 1998 account by
independent counsel Kenneth Starr of the
relationship of President Bill Clinton
to a young White House intern Monica
Lewinsky remember that according to mr.
Starr in the afternoon of the Presidents
Day holiday Monday February 19th 1996
and I'm now quoting from the Star report
the president told miss Lewinsky that he
no longer felt right about there
intimate relationship and he had to put
a stop to it at one point during their
conversation the President had a call
from a sugar grower in Florida whose
name according to Miss Lewinsky was
something like fenoli in Miss Lewinsky
'he's recollection the president may
have taken or returned the call just as
she was leaving the president talked
with Alfonso fan you love Palm Beach
Florida from 12 42 to 104 p.m.
reportedly and now we're back away from
the star report reportedly mr. Vanya had
called the President on a federal
holiday because Vice President Gore had
just announced a plan to tax Florida
sugar growers the proposed tax would
help pay for federal efforts to restore
parts of the Everglades that had been
polluted by sugarcane runoff furthermore
the house was debating whether to phase
out sugar sugar subsidies the time
reporters noted that the tax was never
past their account concluded that access
given that level of connection it's
understandable that agency officials
would want not want to do battle over a
matter so seemingly trivial as the use
of the verb moderate rather than limit
in guidelines about sugar consumption so
much for the sugar Association now as to
what I say about personal responsibility
which I deal with actually quite
extensively in the book because I do
believe that diet is a matter of
personal responsibility however in
context we have seen how the food
industry uses lobbying lawsuits
financial contributions public relations
advertising partnerships and alliances
philanthropy threats and biased
information to convince Congress federal
agencies nutrition and health
professionals and the public that the
science relating diet to health is so
confusing that they not don't need to
worry about diets when it comes to diets
anything goes representatives of food
companies and their trade associations
repeatedly make the following claims
like and I'm sure you've heard these the
keys to healthful diets are balanced
variety and moderation especially when
their products are included all foods
can be part of healthful diets
especially there's there's no such thing
as a good or a bad food
except when their products are
considered good dietary advice changes
so often that we need not follow it
unless it favors their products research
on diet and health is so uncertain that
it is meaningless except when it
supports the health benefits of their
products only a small percentage of the
population would benefit from following
dietary advice if that advice suggests
restrictions on intake of their products
diets are a matter of personal
responsibility and freedom of choice
especially the freedom to choose their
products advocacy for more healthful
food choices is irrational if it
suggests eating less of their products
government intervention and dietary
choice is unnecessary
undesirable and incompatible with
democratic institutions unless it
protects and promotes their products dr.
Rona Applebaum of the national food
processors Association for example
succinctly expresses such views when she
says the diet should conform to the
three principles of sound nutritional
advice balanced variety and moderation
and that societal measures to support
more healthful food choices are
unnecessary changing the environment of
food choices possible she maintains only
and this is a quote if the federal
government in the role of Big Brother
mandates what foods can it cannot be
produced which is not the role of
government in a free market economy
controlling limiting and outright
banning of products deemed unfit does
not work and history attests to the
failure of such extremist measures food
consumption is not supply driven it is
demand driven it's your fault and
consumers are in the driver's seat you
cannot force people to comply with the
dietary guidelines and it is wrong to
try it is an unworkable totalitarian
approach that brings with it all of the
evils associated with such a philosophy
with such statements food industry
officials appeal to emotion in this case
feels that fears of totalitarianism to
argue against something that no
nutrition is private or governmental
advocates nutritionists are simply
trying to educate the public that some
foods are better from health for health
and others the food industry fiercely
opposes this idea and
uses its substantial resources political
skills and emotional Appeals to
discourage attempts to introduce eat
less messages into public discussion of
dietary issues and instead to encourage
people to eat more these tactics and the
part of food companies are in one sense
a routine part of doing business they're
no different from those used by other
large commercial interests such as drug
companies or tobacco companies but
sellers of food products do not attract
the same kind of attention as purveyors
of drugs or tobacco and then I go on to
say we're fortunate to live in a
free-market economy that gives us an
abundant indeed an over abundant food
supply at low cost what we choose to
make of this supply is of course a
matter of personal responsibility as
food company officials are quick to
argue but we do not make food choices in
a vacuum we select diets in a marketing
environment in which billions of dollars
are spent to convince us that nutrition
advice is so confusing and eating
healthfully so impossibly difficult that
there is no point in bothering to eat
less of one or another food product or
category we may believe that we make
informed decisions about food choice but
we cannot do so if we are oblivious of
the ways food companies influence our
choices most of us if we choose to do so
can recognize how food companies spend
money on advertising but it is far more
difficult to know about the industry's
behind-the-scenes efforts in Congress in
federal agencies courts universities and
professional organizations to make diets
seem a matter of personal choice rather
than a deliberate manipulation the
emphasis on individual choice serves the
interests of the food industry for one
critical reason if diet is a matter of
individual free will then the only
appropriate remedy for poor diets is
education and nutritionists should be
off teaching people to take personal
responsibility for their own diet and
health not how to institute societal
changes that might make it easier for
everyone to do so and that's where I'll
stop and take questions thank you very
much
are there questions comments yes oh wait
for the boom could you comment on the
sweetness Splenda and is it really a
good substitute for sugar well I'm
actually in favor of eating sugar
what's wrong with sugar just do it in
moderation sugar but it's a sugar
substitute but it's made from
carbohydrate and it doesn't have any
calories it's an indigestion
carbohydrate that's fine but a little
sugar never hurt anybody
well that's what's so funny about their
anger about this is that's really what I
believe in moderation of course can i
I'm really curious in the introduction
of your book you talked about the fact
that you said over the years you've had
a lot of very genial interactions with
people who are representative is the
food industry people who work in it and
so on I'm really sort of curious if
since the publication of food politics
who found that your relationship has
become less genial and less interactive
and less cordial then I would say if the
book has done one thing it's improved
the quality of my invitations I'm
getting invited to much more interesting
places and at much higher levels
actually the I don't think it's possible
to avoid having interactions with food
companies if you're a nutrition
professional I mean they're in your face
all the time and if I didn't have
personal relationships and cordial
relationships with them I wouldn't be
able to go to meetings I would be in my
office talking to myself all the time
it's still quite civilized I don't think
that the more responsible food companies
have organized their response yet the
books only been out for a month they
haven't read it when they've read it I
don't know what they're going to say
about it the only food industry that
I've heard is from the sugar Association
for the sugar Association the you know
the people who are going to
if I don't stop saying mean things about
sugar though and I will try to use the
word sugars instead of sugar to be more
precise yes I wonder if you could
comment on I guess what I consider to be
the most egregious manipulation of
science for food policy by industry
which is with genetically engineered
food what one of my colleagues refers to
as the evil twin it's coming out this
time next year but yes I'd be happy to
comment on it it's a situation in which
the industry made a decision that they
were going to do this and get government
to collaborate with them in producing
these foods without labeling them I
think if they labelled them it would
have changed a great deal of the
interaction between consumers in the
industry but the fact that that they're
not labeled means that you don't have
any choice I know you cannot exercise
your consumer right to vote with your
fork at the marketplace if you don't
know that the foods are genetically
engineered and I see that as the crux of
the political problem and that was the
decision that the industry fought very
hard for answer because in a way you're
saying that the issue is choice after
all which is what the industry has been
saying well yes I mean if we have a free
market economy let's let's have a level
playing field
right I mean consumers have have a
choice but the industry in that
situation has not given the public a
choice because the foods are not labeled
though and I see that as the crux of the
political problem there are other
problems too but that's the next book
yes I have two questions actually the
first one is in addition to genetic
modifications do you think there are any
there's any other information it's
critical to consumers that's missing
from food labels today and my other
question is do you know of reliable
places to get nutrition information
since so much of it seems to be biased
one way or the other
well that's it that's a hard one yeah I
think the food label is almost
impossible for anybody who isn't a
nutritionist to understand we teach
nutrition students in my department we
spend a lot of time trying to get them
to understand how the food label works
so they can explain how it works to
their clients I mean I don't think that
the Food and Drug Administration was
being deliberately obfuscating when it
set up when it set up the label the way
it did but there are other things that
you might like to know that aren't on
the labels and you have to have a
calculator to figure out you know what
the percentage of fat is which you might
want to know but it's so much of an
improvement over what used to be that we
have to live with it for a while so
that's my answer to that question on the
where you get information about
nutrition you know so much of nutrition
is common sense and if the information
that you're getting doesn't fit with
common sense it's probably wrong I mean
there are textbooks there are lots of
very very good textbooks we like
concepts and controversies which is a
textbook published by wodsworth and we
use that in our department it's easy to
read it's got lots of pictures and lots
of exercises it's I think it's fine but
mostly you know you have to read and
think it's a thinking person's feel then
it requires a lot of critical thinking
at every stage it's not so easy yes
lines how do you propose that we educate
the public especially people from when
they're young so that they understand
have an interest in food issues and that
they have gained an understanding and
they can make choices for themselves
especially how do you deal with the idea
that the problem about especially in the
American four are overwhelmingly
overweight now especially children and
that has to do with education issues and
also how much it is to buy fast food
yeah I don't actually don't think it's
so much a question of Education as I
think it is of just difficulties of life
you know there aren't any supermarkets
in Harlem for example which is the city
that I live in but there plenty of fast
food places and fast food is cheap
there's a reason why fast food is cheap
and it has to do with the way federal
subsidies are distributed what if we
change the way we did federal subsidies
to subsidized fruits and vegetables for
example that might help but it seems to
me that it's a political and you know
obesity is not just a problem among the
poor it's a problem among everybody and
a very difficult one to address if I
were you know I didn't talk about the
political problem that I think is the
most I mean what I think is the most
egregious problem is food marketing in
schools I mean that's my first choice
for if we're going to take political
action let's get the commercialism out
of schools
let's get fast-food out of schools let's
get soft drink contracts out of schools
and let's start teaching kids about
nutrition in health in school where
they're supposed to and not undermine it
with all of the commercialism that's
going on so you know what and that would
affect poor kids as well as rich kids I
just come back from obesity meeting in
Washington where a group of people got
together to talk about um some new
initiatives to try to do something about
the rising rates of overweight and
obesity among young children and these
are people who are in the field and our
pediatricians and are kind of at a loss
as to what to do but where it came down
to was let's do for kids what was done
for kids for cigarettes maybe 20 or 30
years ago where kids were taught to get
their parents to stop smoking maybe kids
need to be taught to
get their caretakers to choose better
diets I don't know anyway it's something
that people are thinking about I'd like
a lot of thought about these kinds of
issues I'm not sure what the solutions
are I don't have easy solutions to any
of these problems but I think they're
worth thinking about and they've been
greatly overlooked yes in a free market
economy but I wonder if the kinds of
things that you're demonstrating is that
we don't perhaps we need a more subtle
kind of Zurn and a free market economy
because it's quite controlled in certain
ways I'm almost using it ironically it's
a you know there are ways in which the
government subsidizes certain kinds of
foods and certain kinds of dietary
practices that were completely unaware
of I mean for example somebody told me
and I'm not actually sure this is true
so let me just put it out as a as a
tentative example but somebody told me
that McDonald's could take the money
that they spend on advertising their
products and subtract that as a business
expense
if that's a bit add vertices a business
expense then taxpayers are subsidizing
marketing the McDonald's marketing I
don't know whether that's true or not so
I'm not I'm a little hesitant about it
but there are loads of ways in which the
government subsidizes corporate food you
know through price supports are only the
most obvious ways for sugar and dairy
products but there are many many other
ways water-rights grazing rights land
uses tax subsidies tax abatements that
could be altered in a different way to
promote a healthier food economy yes is
there any hope that we will have changed
during this current administration or
should we just give up and wait well I
never give up I mean I think this is a
grassroots situation I mean I'm very
impressed by the work of a group in
Oakland California called the Center for
commercial free public education which
has been very effective in organizing
communities to get marketing out of
schools and to turn down soft drink
contracts with schools that's grassroots
it's working from the bottom up I'm very
impressed
with the tremendous outpouring of public
support there was for the Organic
Standards Act when the Organic Standards
Act said it would be okay to label foods
that were genetically engineered
irradiated or treated with sewage sludge
275,000 people wrote in and said no way
and the Department of Agriculture
changed that that means there's a huge
public support for doing something
better about our food supply it's just
that it's organized on the internet and
not necessarily ston the national level
and needs to be local I think I mean I'm
greatly in favor of exercising
democratic rights as citizens starting
local and working with and joining
organizations and working way up and
voting with your fork making individual
choices about what kinds of food you're
going to eat and how you're going to eat
them know I mean I think they're plenty
that individual there's plenty of things
that individuals can do yes Ellen
we live in an era of public-private
partnerships and food industry has been
extremely active in promoting the
government's monitoring of the hunger
situation and also working with
anti-hunger advocates could you talk a
little bit about what you see is the
proper role of the food industry in
these efforts well I've kind of given up
on the food industry I just don't think
that partnerships are possible because
the goals of food companies are so
completely different than the goals of
consumers you know consumers are
concerned about health and the food
industry is concerned about increasing
sales and one of the things I talked
about is this is really big business the
food industry is a nine hundred billion
dollar industry in the United States and
it's one of the big dark secrets of the
American food economy is how enormously
overproduced it is the food industry is
so successful that it produces enough
food in the United States to feed
everybody twice over
well this creates a tremendously
competitive environment in which
companies are fighting with each other
for the consumer food dollar and the
object if you're a food company is to
get people either to buy your product
instead of somebody else's or to get
people to eat more in general and I see
the ways in which companies try to get
people to eat more as contributing to
the obesity problem whether people
realize it or not and there are lots of
ways in which they do that and I go into
them in great detail and so if you're
dealing with food companies you need to
look for congruent you need to look for
congruence well I tell the story about
what I think is the best example which
is fruit and vegetable the five a day
program which is a federal program to
promote consumption of five fruits and
vegetables a day it's a great idea it's
countable if you only have to count to
five you can do it on one and it's
really simple everybody can understand
it you can keep track of it it's really
great but there's no money behind it and
in the peak year in which the government
and private industry got together to
promote public education around five a
day
they put in two million dollars to do
that now two million dollars sounds like
a lot of money to me
it really does however McDonald's spends
about a billion dollars a year to
advertise its products just in the
United States any soft drink coca-cola
any you know big nationally advertised
soft drink spends in the order of a
hundred twenty million dollars a year
any candy bar is 50 to 70 million
dollars a year
any sweetened cereal is 15 million
dollars a year and Altoid mints which
for some reason other I love to use as
an example has a ten million dollar a
year advertising budget altogether
there's thirty billion dollars in food
advertising so you stacked that very
large number with all those zeros up
against two million dollars and it's
nothing it's nothing there's never been
a nutrition education campaign in this
country of any kind of stature at all so
I don't know Ellen if you're talking
about food distribution programs and
giveaway programs and all of that kind
of thing
but for that I recommend Jan pop and eke
splendid book Sweet Charity which talks
about the role of food companies in food
distribution programs to the poor a very
complicated issue
you give us a peek into the culture of
nutritionists I imagine you in your
classes you know and teaching people and
then some leave to go work for the food
industry and some for a PMO's and yeah
and will your book be read and you know
nutrition schools and I certainly hope
so
I certainly hope it will be read and
will be required reading in a lot of
nutrition certainly will be in our
classes but the the I think the
nutrition nutrition as a profession is
going to have to deal with the issues
that I raised you know I thought I was
stating the obvious that food is a
business duh
you know I mean it's and it's just
something that's never talked about and
I give specific examples I have a whole
chapter on food companies relationships
with food and nutrition professionals in
which I do complete disclosure of my own
relationships because in doing the
research for the book I had to go back
and look at for example my 12-year
relationship with Procter and Gamble
which for trail 12 years tried to bring
me on board in a way that was so subtle
I didn't even know that it was happening
to bring me on board as a promoter of
olestra which I never did do but yeah it
was I mean I was impressed in reviewing
that then it was a 12-year effort that
it involved a their head of public
relations needs to come to New York
quite frequently to take me to dinner it
involved going to meetings in New
Orleans that were gorgeous lavish hotels
I mean I could go on and on I think it's
impossible for a nutritionist to not be
involved with food companies because
they sponsor all the meetings and
journals
all of them they also sponsor research
that's more problematic and I have in
the book a table of research studies I
had no trouble at all going through the
research literature and picking out
studies that were done that came out
with results favorable to the sponsor of
that study I had no trouble at all it
took me an hour of just browsing through
my files let's find one on sugar let's
find one on eggs let's find one on fat
and cholesterol let's find one I just
notoya let's find one on vitamins i me
just had no trouble at all
lots of in of food research is sponsored
by the companies that make the products
that are involved and you know that them
if i talk to the researchers should do
those studies and say do the companies
influence the quality of your research
the interpretation of your research how
you think about the research of course
not you know they're just outraged
except for people who take me aside
afterwards and say i can't talk to you
on the record about this you must never
never never quote me but when we came
out with these results the company that
was sponsoring them asked us to change
the data or the company that said we
they really didn't want us to publish it
or i mean these kinds of things happen
they're just not public and it's that
kind of thing that it seems to me I mean
I have a I had a very deliberate thing
that I wanted done I want the American
Dietetic Association to get rid of its
fact sheets they have Nutrition Facts
sheets on their website each one with
its own corporate sponsor guess who
sponsored the genetic engineering one
Monsanto guess who sponsored the one on
on soft drinks which says that soft
drinks are a good way to quench your
thirst
my friends of the sugar Association or
whoever it is I mean you can name the
topic on which you would like advice and
then there's a corporate sponsor and
when members of the American Dietetic
Association challenged that and said gee
these things sound like they were
written by the public relations offices
of these companies guess what they were
they work so I want them to stop that or
you know issue number one I think that
that organization and I'm not taking on
that organization particularly except
that it does things in some ways more
openly than a lot of the other nutrition
organizations but I think they should
not have sponsored sessions at their
annual meetings I gave a talk on
biotechnology at a sponsored session a
couple of years ago that was sponsored
by month by Monsanto it just put me in a
terrific quandary what am I supposed to
do do I say no to the invitation and
then I lose the opportunity to talk to
an audience that I particularly want to
influence do I not take any money in
which case I'm out several thousand
dollars because it's a very expensive
meeting and the travel cost a lot do I
turn down the honorarium that's what
that's what I did but the you know I
take my policy on this finally after
much agonizing is to take travel money
from food companies if that's the way
you know I'll take travel in hotel and
that kind of expenses I'll go to
meetings that are sponsored and I will
speak it's sponsored sessions and I will
go to food companies and speak to people
at food companies if they invite me I
don't get invited very often but once in
a while I do I did speak to Monsanto
once a few years ago it was a very
interesting experience and but I don't
take honoraria personally I asked the
companies if there is an honorarium to
donate it to our department scholarship
account now you may think that that's
selling out and I don't know it's the
best I can do and it would came after a
lot of agonizing about how to deal with
it it's a big problem but I do suffer
over it then I'll say that in my favor
anything else
well thank you very much appreciate it I
just want to again thank you all for
coming and thank you personally for
singing we do have copies of the book
available at the front of the store I'd
love it people could buy some and
Professor that's looking signed some
maybe I'd be happy marion Nestle is
nutrition chair at New York University
and editor of the 1988 Surgeon General
report she's the author of food politics
how the food industry influences
nutrition and health it's published by
university of california press online at
UC press e tu